[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu m'as tu sais rien je suis loin de
monde
ça ne faisait aucun doute pour ma part
voilà c'était votre cadeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
car merci à toutes les équipes de
production et des vip
ils sont embêtés à faire tout ça pour ça
voilà mais ça c'était important de le
dire
mathieu on vous retrouve tout tous les
jours sur nrj12 à 17h30 et aux tensions
17h30
qu'est-ce que tu pouvais lui j'avais
jamais fait attention allez-y faites
vous plaisir
s'il va toucher il faut y aller vas-y
bébé entraide rue ah non c'est pas de
rue et cela parce que j'ai mis du dojo
bas mais voulait toucher mais très peu
touché également à les y aller je vois
tu es donc 17h03 17